Mary do you have those tough life
stories in it yeah ready what was that
guys we got some construction downstairs
we hit a load-bearing wall we need to
get out of here right now all right all
right Ryan oh my god let's go oh my god
Josh let's go what you think you're
going what news now YouTube go I'm out
oh hey I'm Mary this is games on news
top 5 August seventh
okay first of all there was a fake swap
prank that went wrong and it got a
league of legends streamer band get out
of my way every minute group self
trick2g is a regular League of Legends
streamer on twitch viewers of his stream
know him for his insane antics and
off-the-wall persona after he faked
getting swatted on stream in front of
viewers trick2g was banned from using
twitch a streaming platform for the next
four months trick 2 g's fan base has
been defending the streamer saying the
incident was all in good fun demanding
that twitch list their ban fans have
popularized the hashtag free trick on
Twitter when asked at which
representative informed GameSpot that
they do not comment on Terms of Service
violations and next up are all the free
games you get in August when you have
xbox gold or playstation plus if you
have xbox gold on xbox one you get metal
gear solid 5 ground zeroes and how to
survive storm warning edition if you
have 360 from august 1st through the
15th you get metro 2033 and from the
16th through the 31st you get metro last
light if you have playstation plus
you're getting castlestorm complete
edition on ps3 and Vita stealth Inc to a
game of clones on ps4 ps3 and Vita god
of war ascension on ps3 Laura Croft in
the temple of Osiris on ps4 sound shapes
on ps4 ps3 and Vita and limbo on ps4
josh is just go through here
alright there's a there's a new wow
expansion that adds a class raises the
level cap and more crap the lights went
out alright I think there's a fuse box
over here the expansion pot Legion as a
new continent named broken Isles never
been playable in World of Warcraft
before but it was referenced in Warcraft
3 what's more Legion raises the World of
Warcraft's level cap to 110 and
introduces a new class called demon
hunter there's also new dungeons and
raids to explore as well as new artifact
weapons and an honor system we already
expected fallout 4 to be a really long
game but we're finding out just how long
the game really is josh
you're going to be playing fallout 4 for
a really long time the lead producer of
fallout 4 SETI's played the
post-apocalyptic RPG for 400 hours
already and he's still not seen
everything it has to offer he went on to
say that this is partly result of the
game's crafting system which is
extensive and intricate he talked about
how players will need to scavenge for
very specific items fallout 4 launches
on November 10th for xbox one
playstation 4 and pc okay Josh the doors
locked Josh doors locks cool let's go go
run okay um okay so one of the biggest
stories of the week is that Bungie hired
nolan north to be the voice of the of
the ghosts in destiny what what's really
weird about it is that he's recording
all of the lines and completely
replacing Peter Dinklage Josh what do I
do
that's right the dinkle bot is no more
according to Destiny's lead concept
artist jessi van dyk the significant
change was needed to guide players more
they needed more lines recorded and then
that ended up with nolan north being
hired not just for the new lines but for
all the Lions according to bungee they
wanted the whole universe to be
consistent which means nolan north is
your ghost from the very moment you
start the game the taken King launches
on September 15th well thank God okay
great that was the top 5 news you guys
who made it just to be back next week so
there's that and I hope you guys had a
really good time have a great weekend
you